[Music]
wedding planning is going great we're
we're trying to see if we still want to
do the TV side of things or if we want
to do privately bachelor Ari lion Dyke
jr. sharing a wedding planning update
only with a teeth at Indy cars Toyota
Grand Prix in Long Beach I want to let
you know that I do feel confident in all
this because I love you re and fiance
Lauren Burnham just moved in together
about two weeks ago and he says their
dynamic has already changed for the
better it's been really fun actually her
dog Dallas is so cute and he gets along
with my dog so and we're looking at
houses and it's really an exciting time
of life so for me it's been really cool
I think it's strengthened our
relationship we love hanging out
together and we're very similar so we
get along and it's just great it's been
so easygoing I think that the biggest
part is just sort of not paying too much
close attention to social media we like
to post and share our lives with people
but we also don't really dive into the
comments and we want to be positive ari
and Lauren seem committed to making this
relationship work
last week the lovebirds met with
marriage boot camp counselors dr. ish
and dr. V at the Arizona Biltmore we
went to lunch of them just to hear about
their show and they gave us a lot of
good advice and it's always good to get
advice it doesn't hurt
so we've also met with Lauren's pastor
at her church so it's good to really you
know lean on people that you know can
shed some light on how to help your
relationship
you